joining me now for the latest on this
military campaign now one month old uh
general keith kellogg general great to
see you let's just look at where we're
at right now you've been following us as
close as anyone in america here's the
map the red is russia the blue areas of
which ukraine is defending what concerns
you most from the ukrainian perspective
yeah brian thanks for having me well i
think there first of all the ukrainians
are fighting with incredible courage
and the great leadership and starting
with zielinski and i think what you're
looking at is the russians have stalled
out and my concern right now is that
they're really going to load up and
they're going to have to go after keeve
keeves actually is is the the crown
jewel that's the king on the chessboard
they've got to take keeve that's where
the center of government is that's where
zielinski's at and if they don't take
key they actually lose the problem is i
don't think they can take it uh without
rebelizing it and what i mean by that
they're going to bring in a lot of
artillery they're going to do the same
thing you saw mirapool and car cave and
just
shell the heck out of it because that
they have to take it right here's what's
interesting to me is that looking at the
map right now yeah let's take a look at
them they're about as extended as they
can be well if you go to the map right
now
it looks to me like he's going to really
focus on eastern ukraine not the west he
does not have the troops to task to move
to the west i think if i was going to
predict this if he can take keeve and
i'm not saying he can right but if putin
can take it i think what he'll say is
okay let's call it a day let's negotiate
now i own the eastern part of ukraine
you've got the western part of ukraine
if you drew the line on the nipper river
this is the new river i just put it in
red right here so go back to the map
and and that gives you that gives him
the sanctuary he wants but if he doesn't
get it he doesn't take keem he's got a
major problem he does he can't get to
the west that is actually badland
territory that's another 400 miles to
the west right he's going to extend his
logistics lines he's going to be facing
a lot of nato allies out there uh the
nato alliance out there i think he just
may call it a day because he's not
winning at all if i had if this was a
prize fight right now brian
right now zielinski's winning on points
so you also told me about this
look at the south they had the donbass
region obviously they had crimea that's
all red but you look at here this is the
only city that he's won so far and
they're pushing back other ukrainians i
hear this is just tremendous uh street
to street fighting uh mikalev they're
fighting like real uh spartans but
they're trying to block odessa could you
see a scenario and by the way a ton of
fighting here and there's a sense within
mirapool uh that they could lose the
city sometime this weekend can you see a
scenario where he gets odessa and says
okay i got my buffer zone
war over i win even though we know the
losses and the humiliation and his goal
was to win in two or three days and it's
already been 24. could you see that
brian i can't because he will realize
that he cannot take all of ukraine to
the west he'll also realize that he's
now
what's happening with the sanctions in
the entire world pressure on them
that he's going to try to cut the best
deal he can and as long as we can keep
zielinski alive we're okay remember just
a few days ago the internet and internet
international court of justice at the
hague voted 13-2 to say this is genocide
and this is a war crime right you know
he's facing a lot of uphill activities
right now and i think the biggest one of
the ukrainians pushing back and again
and i really mean this if if zielinski
can hold on to keeve and they can hold
that city i think they're going to win
this fight you know you go into a city
you know normally you want to have a
three to one advantage when you go into
a fight that's you're gonna need about a
ten to one advantage and he doesn't have
the troops to task to do that right now
he's bringing troops in from moscow he's
extended everything yeah begging china
for help we only have 25 seconds you
have one out of the box thought you want
to leave us with today about finland
yeah look
we need an interlocutor and we have to
find somebody who can talk to putin and
i'd go to the president of finland uh
president ninosu who knows putin has
been with him finland has a history of
defeating the police coming to a draw
with the soviets in 39 and 40 in the
russo finnish war and nunestow is a very
seasoned politician he's the one we
should go to and say look yeah become
the interlocutor for us talk to putin
let's see where we're at they haven't
done it yet they should right we can't
wait to talk we got to figure out the
right terms let's get some tactics and
stop reacting lieutenant general keith
kellogg always great always educational
thanks so much
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else